you
[Music]
great so welcome back we're going to
have two talks and then we'll break for
lunch lunch will be provided here in
this room first in this next session
we're going to hear from Chevy whoo he's
going to tell us about quantum query
complexity of entropy estimation does
the mic work okay okay okay
yes thanks for inviting me here I so I
actually recently joined the university
Maryland in this quake center just for
you to advertisement here I think you're
all welcome to visit us at some time and
it's actually uh I feel very honored to
give a talk in this you know venue
especially for topic that I just this is
my first working on our zone it's type
of our zone and before I'd really try
about to watch I have down I want to
give you some my own motivations of why
I choose to work on this type of problem
so so actually I start all this kind of
work by first reading a survey on
content probably testing by Montanaro
and Dorff so thanks for this away yeah
so I find this is very interesting it's
a it's a topic which is actually uh
classically there are lots of research
going on that we have seen lots of
examples can be characterized as
probably testing but there's no in
overseer study of this topic and this is
a you know the main motivation and it
would start with something simple we'd
say how about we try to started
contesters of classical properties and
I'm over I choose to work on the testing
of distributional properties again it's
a well motive the topic in the classical
literature and moreover if you maybe
attend the talks in the Paris three days
about machine learning so distribution
of Harvard's testing is quite a similar
to say if we have like latent of modo or
you know English learning you want to
learn about those parameters or you want
to just tell in which case it is so
potentially have connection to the
running province as well
I think it
in the same and the third one is that
the objects and distributions they're
not you know boolean functions so we see
have seen a lot of the result on boolean
functions the distributions might bring
new insights or call for new techniques
so this three points motivated me to
start this kind of question and of
course we you know try to intrusive one
question you know gotta start with some
and concrete I think I start with
something that you know it's quite a
well-known a probably the most easier
one you just want to introduce so my
partners that are talking about you know
estimating entropy of any distribution
so I guess the audience here of public
familiar is counsel after just to run
should you quickly go straight so for
any dispute in the Shannara p is define
in this form it's actually are captures
like it uncertainty you or maybe running
this of this description and important
generalization of the Shannon entropy
it's the rainy entropy it can be defined
for any positive alpha and when this so
this is a general description for there
any entropy and when our effort goes
through one its limit yet becomes the
Shannon entropy so our loads to two are
very important quantities in information
theory and also you can use that to
characterize many properties of the
distribution so a natural question in
the probably testing literature is
basically say if I give you Santos
independently draw from this kind
descriptions I want us to mate this
entropy or sorry the Shannon entropy or
any entropy with within some arrow with
high probability I want you to determine
what's the you know meter smallest
number of samples that I need for that
rivers as I said this is the theoretical
peering topic and also it's very clean
this has the intimate connection to
statistics information see our a
learning theory and even a version
design so the question we're asking here
is that is any quantum speed-up for this
tap as I said in the beginning I think
this question alliance with the emergent
avocado quantum every testing but this
one is focus on distributional property
does
so the first paper you know smile test
knowledge on this topic its library
Harrow and they have seen which they
started the quantum speed-up for testing
distribution poverty like uniformity
orthogonality and SPC hood this also
follow a wonderful follow-up work I
think by a cherub for he I think it's
also in mode oh okay so but but I what I
want to say is that it's all actually
the only to reference I have found so
we're sort of one in the play
it's actually after several years we you
know found this might be an interesting
part when you explore further so what's
our may result so before talking about
our results let's just tell you a little
bit about what's the castor is out so
this is a world star department so
imagine classically this is a simple
complexity or number of the independent
samples there's target bounds already uh
being sport they actually are you know
this has been discovered in information
community first and then discovered by
the you know theoretical science
community we're you know they use
different kind of error measure and also
you know care about different parameters
so in some community they don't really
care about long term but some do care
so for shannon entropy the best bounds
so far so this is a the valiant brothers
is in theoretical person science
community and this is the firaon
information theory community they all
give this sim downs is almost just
linear this is linear and over login and
for general any entropy the story is a
little bit more complicated but this key
or de vidas are possible a pinches three
are different parts the parts between
journal one the parts are bigger than 1
but not integers and part that it's
integers so we see more clearly with the
picture in average sides but what you
can see is that even our
between zero and one it's true beautiful
in here and when authorized non-integer
it's almost linear and when our fads
interviewers then you can get something
better so here's the list of her result
so this is the classic one I just showed
and this is basically all this result we
have in you know the total value in this
talk and also this the working company
know first coming paper so basically we
give all this quant upper bounds and
also lower bounds for all different
range of alpha so so let me use this
picture to illustrate that so you can
just come back and forth to compared to
retail so let me just to describe this
figure so what does mean so this x-axis
is our this aha
and there's y-axis represent these
exponent of n for the a versa so say if
you're looking at Y being one that means
a linear is anything below this means
sub linear and this is a super linear
and the green line or the classical
bounce because it's also if it's both
the upper bound and the lower bound so
you can see for any Alpha bigger than
one it's almost a linear except
furloughs indeed your points which you
can do something better and for anything
smaller than one you have super in your
function like this so our upper bounds
quantum every bounce is some is the red
line so for which we still have you know
you know similar ship but it's like for
you know the interval between 0 and 1 to
the shift it shift it down so you see
that's the quantum speed-up because we
can get some stuff linear even for our
from between 0 and 1 and we can get all
speed as you know eventually it's just
you know not a magic speed as when our 4
goes to infinity that it is this
strictly sub linear for any Arva and for
integer alpha we can do you know
slightly better than the classic reverse
in the soil
we also approve the quanta lower bounds
which is illustrated by the pink line
and we you know combining our upper
bound and lower bounds we have shown for
Xfinity in the reigning - entropy which
is the collegian entropy we have a tight
bound that's a cube a cube root of n so
just coming back to you with this table
so this is the precise bound we have
show so as I said for our vehicle's true
we have the tidal bound like this it's a
cube in complexity compared to classic
code of square root of n for Shannon
entropy
that's our Phi equals 1 we have a square
root of in Missouri Korea quadratic
speed a bow which is the classical bound
and okay for all the others of since we
have lower bounds there still gap
between our upper bound in between want
our in our current result so I have to
actually give a a similar talking and
Microsoft Research in April so if you're
having two sitting this in my talking
April so this is actually the picture I
give back then so the only difference is
that we have improved our results for
general alpha case where this is what we
get for at April we only have the
quantities we have within you know very
small range of alpha now what I can show
is you can achieve actually content
speed up for all possible or you know
powerful okay so any prints the form
so let's talk a little bit about a
technique so in a high level of answer
before I really want to talk about the
technique I want to mention there's the
Saturday in the model with you know I
mentioned I'll classically imagine when
you really care about simple capacity
you have independent draws for some
description but if we want to you know
allow content you have some advantage
you're probably well imagine you have
some quantum coherent access to the
distribution but if you're giving
classical independent samples that just
makes it impossible for you have any
like a quantum coherent access to the
description so one of the contribution
by this BBOB hhf work is they propose
Oracle model to describe the
distribution so precisely just imagine
you're there's the Oracle function for
any distribution p over like a disk
reset so it's a function mapping from a
very large domain into n it's the
support of this description and each p I
will be just looking at the size of your
imager for each I and divided by the
size of the input domain s so as can be
actually so for any this kind of Oracle
of a set for any distribution they can
be many articles satisfy this property
and you can see here as all this period
should be rational numbers so we make
another restriction we're not already
considering irrational distribution
which actually is reasonable since you
cannot really story rational never seen
on computers so if you just use this
Oracle and samples uniformly from this
input you look at output you can exactly
recover in a sample that is strong from
the distribution P so does that mean set
so this is just you know stronger model
then you just in the kitty when you only
can get a sample from the scan
description but why does this also
reasonable model
one justification is that in BH image
this show if you count the you know the
current capacity over this article mode
obviously the number of quests who makes
you this article and also count the
simple complexity in the model where you
only allow use independent samples from
the distribution it can show the actual
equivalent it's using the classical city
so that's a justification of this model
and I think there's the further
justification which you've imagined in
some application where the description
actually generated it by something like
this if you imagine you're in Arizona
maybe you add further justice a some
kind distribution and you want to
distinguish which case it is but the way
you're generated outputs it should be
something like this Oracle function so
so that makes me think this Oracle model
can also be readily useful for our some
design if you have a version for this
type of you know Oracle model of the
distribution so that's what we are going
to use for in the content setting so
this if you use that article other than
it's quantum version it's very
straightforward you just imagine you
turn this function into a unitary and
you can make a query to this function in
a by getting into the app and the
observers outfit again the you know from
here the we just need to care about the
query capacity of using this organ
function so here's the roadmap of our
techniques which we handle all different
cases of artha we basically have a four
different cases and I you know quickly
just go through one by one give you some
high-level idea so in the very very
basic kind of high-level pictures that
we try to give you a general
distribution property estimation problem
so this is even a more general than the
Dre apartment round result but I the the
questions that you have some kind
description given by this Oracle I'm
asking to approximate F P which is the
sum P I times FBI
FBI can be any function and we want to
estimate this with to some error with
high probability if we choose this FX
should be log - la vie accidents that
few of your general entropy so that's
one case we're thinking about the other
case will be if we choose FX should be X
to the Alpha minus 1 then this reading
entropy well proportional to the
logarithm of FP so our final goal is to
achieve additive - I mean additive
errors for HP or x RP then in the first
case we care about additive error for
approximately this FP in the second case
we care about the multiplicative error
of a person exactly so what we have down
stand we basically just to formulate
ideas in bhh and it proposes a simple
framework for our personality in this FP
so the idea is that you first just
assemble any I to according to the
distribution of P that's easy to do
because you already have Oracle you can
simple any I like that and then we use
amplitude and the estimation so that's
the quantum saying we estimate this
probability P I altitude is estimated
superior of the P I and why we can do
that it's again by definition so the P I
will be the period the size of the
preimage over the size of a domain so in
order to approximate the P I just need
to do some kind of counting and we know
you know that's something you can do
there's a quantum tunneling algorithm so
we can you know out for the estimation
of the PR tilde and I out for this at P
I so we have some you know further steps
you are you know on top of the
subroutine that it's easy to see if we
just look at this part the output of the
expectation of X will be just in a
summation P IFPI you know hopefully if
the Pieta is good as estimate of P I so
the expectation of this subroutine a
already is something we want but you can
imagine intuitively the performance of
this a version what it turns down you
know its expectation as well as its
variance
or maybe how concentrate this output
distribution will be around the
expectation so of course we want the
output a spectator as close as possible
to the real value we want to estimate
and also we want variance is small so
this of course is just the one simple
you know framework you can use you can
use in other framework so the good thing
about this framework is that it seems
very intuitive is you know this might be
the first thing you want to try and you
know you might study maybe what should
left is just do some calculation
although you want to do the calculation
of the expectation as the variance that
could be very very tedious and a
complicated for you know you know
different kind of F that they actually
if you just do that
you're find out you only have very
limited upon a speed-up you cannot
achieve the hospital as a illustrating
this picture
and actually this is not a really
unusual if you're looking to the
classical literature they have something
like this you know very basic estimator
they're going to use they only give you
something very limited speed as well so
you always need to have some new ideas
and new techniques you handle you know
in for the general case so which is
straight light ER but so so what's going
on after the slides will be I will tell
you first if you just use this kind of
framework what you can do and this is
the case for the Shannon entropy so if
you just use this kind of framework and
the comparing to what's has done in VHS
we have a two new ingredient which the
first one is Montoneros algorithm force
was what it calls quanta speed-up of the
moaning hello message
it's just imagine you have any quantum
procedure it has a pro-x and has
variance upper bounded by a sigma square
and there's a you know quantum awaken
leverage is this circuit of a and a
inverse only use just big big o of the
cig of sigma however absolute at times
of a and a inverse you output a very
good estimate of its expectation just so
this is the core Jack Expedia of
the best again during the classical
setting where you need to have Sigma
square of Epsom square so we leverage
this tool another tool we are need to
use is that we for this particular
function FX of also equals minus log P
we need to have the fine tune an SS to
bound the value of the log of our P when
P is very close to zero this is very
unique to the Shannon entropy case but
basically just leverage in allows true
idea as well as the basic framework so
this is what we can get we can get a big
order of square root of n credit complex
to you for Shannon entropy case which is
quadratic we got for the over the
classical one the extending this idea to
you know general Rennie entropy is
troublesome and that's you know what I
going to talk about for general Rennie
entropy so why is the troublesome the
the main issue is in when we talk about
in the Shannon entropy you're looking
for attitude errors you're looking for
attitude error will guarantee and this
is a good you know
Kojak to speed up by montoneros
algorithm but for general ramey entropy
you're actually looking for the
multiplicative version of this in a
concentration of major question and it
turns out you know there's almost no to
be that in the worst case if you're
looking to what we know you know about
this general problem and if you just
naively use the same framework
you only get a point at one page between
a you know half and a two for this alpha
this is actually this is what we're
getting a proton you know in the picture
I have show you so what we have down you
know in the path to mount it's try to
get of in a round of this obstacles and
here are a few new observations so the
first one is that we we found out if we
can you know in at once have some
knowledge about where the expectation
might be assume like expection wall
being some interval A to B where B is
actually just a big of a then we can
develop very until from a general
algorithm with codec speed up but this
objection by the self
since not very useful because in that
case you already have some kind of
constant in aerial you know multiple a
very version estimate of this
expectation because a and B they're
within constant factors so this is
myself is not that useful
the second observation is that we we
think you know we we don't know this a
and I mean you know once the how about
we use something else to give you
estimate for a and B so we observe that
if we look into the problem we want to
estimate basically this is the Sigma I
pH and artha we look at this function
for different artha so how about you
know when we try to estimate the PIO and
if you are welcome at it maybe p up a
prime such that the result of PF up
front can help me to give a discount
interval for P alpha so what we found is
when this r1 and r2 are very close
enough you know within this factor then
if you have estimated in PR for two then
this will give you a very good estimate
of PR 1 ab s-- you some interval
constant actors and this can be fitting
to the first serum and they give you
some project speed up the question they
reduced you how about she you try to
find some way to estimate a PR for to
you know it's a similar problem so the
idea is the other we just you know
recursively do this and so every time we
start with p f1 we found MP upper to and
then we you know forearm PR for two we
found maybe PR for three such that this
is the sequence of this are how well try
qu in the moves towards one so why what
you want to move towards one it's
because we already know when alpha is
very close to one there's one speed-up
so that will be the boundary case and
but of course we don't directly use the
death interval you can even further
immigrants freedom that procedure so as
a high-level what you are see well we
are we
Arthas bigger than one you just keep you
know multiply alpha with something you
know smaller than one and keep you know
going into your RF it's very close one
and when offers between 0 and wine just
multiply something and it keeps you know
increase our Valente oh it's very close
one so if you do the calculation because
the factor we're using you probably just
roughly use big ol login cause of this
procedure I am then you know four by
using this Technic and actually the NSS
is it's not a very easy to carry it
carries through that you should be very
careful that you eventually you can get
the speed up for all possible alpha so
one thing I want to highlight here is
that if you probably have seen something
similar before either in simulating an
alien ders like cooling to get rose or
maybe in a wet estimation of high
dimension in your comics body there's
some you know it's like a multi section
multiplicative factors thing I actually
the the design principle actually very
you know similar although we we didn't
see those a person before we really have
a solution but then we find out they're
actually something already there but
their difference is that we need to
adapt this kind of them principle to our
context so I think this is something in
a similar in spirit of edge the
techniques are still quite different in
details now let's move to the remaining
two cases
so there's another case about the
integers which we already see
consequently you can have you know
something better than non integers alpha
and you can actually do something
similar in the quantitating so why is
that so we can just you know Lucas
through the capital case and it gives
some inspiration to classically when you
try to estimate a training entropy for
any integer alpha this part actually
connects to something causes are for
frequency moment so what's the arc of
frequency moment just imagine you have
like a sequence of you know those
numbers from the domain and it counts
dalkýran selves loads members
and like them should be just m12 mm so
this will all be SK defined to be
summation I am I to the K well we just K
frequency moment and the key observation
actually very easy to see is that so
this is the draining entropy definition
and this is the what we get it from the
frequency moment is it actually there
simply because you already know am the
just for information this is actually
now the best classic OST meter I won't
tell your wife that she can imagine this
is the empirical thing not always best
this you know simcha seeing our
continent sitting as well so we want to
leverage this connection so instead of
you know directly estimating this P I
and it you know estimating using our
basic framework we want you just
estimating this in our frequency moment
and unfortunately there's the algorithm
of doing that but there's a you know to
did you know issues with you know in
executing this idea the first one is
they are classically in order to find
its frequency moment you need to know
the sum the histogram of your samples
and you need to choose m and we cannot
do that we cannot just say generate
loves em because in that case they
already have the same capacity as
classical ones so so there's a trick
then we make use of the structure of the
content Oracle we just say imagine not
you give the are to a different meaning
now just say this is the input domain
but you imagine this one should ask just
to sum in a sequence and they use six
this s so all you want to do well be
just to get the Alpha Chris employment
of this the sequence of applying this
Oracle to each of the element in the
input domain and you can get exactly you
know something pointy similar to what
you would get with the the Alpha
frequency domain if you have like m
samples and there's another issues that
if you use this idea if you know put
into the the best pony gerson for after
Ferguson moment in your see the
dependence is actually on F naught n so
n is the
the support of this also demand that the
axis size of impediment so as it's
actually you know some kind of
irrelevant parameters so so what we have
done you know rapidly it's that you can
replace that for a friend in this
particular algorithm and the Redoute NSS
it's not a black box way to you know sit
as to the FM but somehow when you look
into the analysis with a virgin and
particulars for this problem you can do
that and then we can somehow you know
put this dependence on n the right in a
parameter rather than F so the finally
there's the case will be the me entropy
kiss me entropy you want to find maximum
of the probability of P I and because
already has the algorithm for general
alpha or in a bit have some for general
any Java natural gets well be you
probably can choose some alpha such that
in which is integer and this gives you
some linear a capacity and they use that
as a good estimation for the h mean so
unfortunately cannot do that the reason
is that when I talk about the integer
alpha this is a big field of sorry the
children bigger hides the exponential
dependence on alpha and when you try to
use this approach it actually can
quickly go you know beyond linear so
this is the false hope so we actually do
have another reduction so the reduction
again it should the this thing is
problem that is to the log and distinct
rabbit
so roughly so what we have down so we
have to use a technique in the classical
literature called personalized sampling
so the idea it's actually coming from
how to divide the best Acacio estimators
and that's also the reason why i say the
empirical estimator for reading
attribute is not the best one you need
to use some technical of optimization
and the end result will be you're
generating some totem distributions that
is primary provide TI and you get value
of pi which are called london and
there's a another fact since the log n
it's actually natural cut out for
the personal description so it's
actually independent of the problem that
you I think it's a fact for the pulse on
description so the the rough idea will
be it's this lambda times the maximum P
I passing some a certain threshold this
V you know that your me entropy passes
certain threshold then with high
probability you can expect to the
occurrence of you know your samples will
have the login collegian and you can use
the log indistinct problem to find this
collision otherwise you may be you know
the your lambda is not good it you gets
values not good it's just a Bolivia
lambda and try again so there won't be
many you know twice of this lambda so in
a your down so the most costly compacity
in this procedure will be the algorithm
for solving log in collision problem and
actually something i am measuring the
open question section so I'll probably
quickly skip the content lower bounce so
you see this pink line which is not that
satisfactory that give you something it
is
we option thereby reduction and the
polynomial method so so there are two
questions I think this is very
interesting is you know immediately risk
by our turn results the first one is we
show a reduction from you know to the
entropy kids estimation to the log in a
distinct problem and if you are try to
investigate the current
ConAgra some via venice and the gloves
you know and you know putting in this
caicos login and then you receive you
know all of them out there action don't
give you any saponin speed-up but
there's no lower balancer data case
either so you don't know you know what's
the real case and another open question
i think is interesting is that
classically when people design this
estimators they're they actually many
mean different kind of techniques that
in the quantum setting we just try the
one particular approach and you can see
quantum speed-up but we haven't really
leveraged classical you know techniques
so can we leverage the design principle
of a classic glass and testers into our
quantum design that's another question
and you remember there's still gaps
between our in my
on a per bound and clinic lower bound
and I think this is also interesting
century Explorer thanks for your
attention
great thank you other questions for
Chevy
you show this plot where the classical
bound was tied whereas your quantum
upper and lower bounds only touched a
single point mm-hmm what is your what do
you think is your upper bound something
that you should try to improve or your
lower bound in order to match the two
curves oh and I think that's very good
question I actually hope I can improve
both them both so I think this should be
meeting some middle point but I can let
me just quickly go back you know this
picture I only have a try to ban Erwin
when our four equals two so what
allowance is the at a church ever took
you know a point on this from the a
program you know point I don't think we
have the where to the understanding of
what will be the right estimators you
see we use very natural estimators and
classically people point out issue with
the second estimators the main issues
that the the natural estimators can
cause some unexpected in a large
variance so you want to have the very
small then you need to some use
something not that natural I mean
somehow you know by using the I think
partially major theory or you know using
polynomial to approximate a in some
something like that and we haven't used
this any of this kind of edir for our
program so it could be improve and from
the lower bound perspective assist that
so we option is lower bounded by just
reducing the program to putting function
progress it's like collegian or maybe
use it at polynomials a method for lower
bound for the collegiate program then
you see what we really have is not
really a putting function property you
want to estimate this entropy and over
distribution so I just say you know
probably we just don't have the right
tool for the lower bound either so I
also you know probably can improve them
both and you can have a better picture
so another question
well Stephanie prepares great
what about the gate complexity of your
algorithms okay - compacity uh that's uh
I mean I really haven't really do the
calculation but you see our algorithm is
simple so that means the simple
compacity or the prayer time person is
almost the running time as well because
oh it's on amplitude amplification sorry
because it's all emplou - simplification
and estimation yeah yeah just that you
know and almost nothing else
great let's think Chevy again for a
terrific talk next up we have Stephanie
Verner and she's going to talk about the
quantum Internet and the certifiable
road ahead and yes sir thanks for
inviting me it's a pleasure to be here
and I'm going to like go into a
different direction now we talked a lot
about kind of quantum computing so I
will talk about quantum Internet and I
guess because I gather is actually
especially in the last two days that
even to some of the quantum people it's
not totally clear and from what we want
a cheesy I wanted to give a bit of an
overview and but to put this a little
bit into perspective I actually would
first wanted to ask you a question which
is who can tell me what happened on this
day 29th of October 1969
all right well I can tell you usually
people say the moon landing that would
snow and so in fact at this day in fact
the first message was transmitted over I
guess what is now called to the Internet
both which at this point in time was
extremely small and these people here
actually exhaust language at this point
a grad student in Los Angeles who
communicated to Stan you can see they
worked hard like a half past 10:00 in
the evening and they sent the first
message and I'll tell you a bit how this
went in fact to check they called each
other on the phone they typed in a
letter in Los Angeles and a sense t gcd
l because i reply singh is excellent
through CDL so they typed the OL and
they ask on the phone DBC the own reply
comes from Stanford saying yes to see
the oh sorry two letters so then they
type the G and and the system crashed
so it can sort of see that obviously a
little bit has happened since kind of
the first message was transmitted over
the classical internet actually several
hours later they succeeded in
transmitting the entirety of login and
and the Internet is quite pervasive
today but you can sort of think that
kind of with a quantum internet we are
maybe of the brink of kind of a similar
situation as we see here for example in
the Netherlands we are trying to set up
a guest currently on track
and sort of demonstration network
between two four cities in the
Netherlands and in by the end of 2020
and so I tell you hear something about
the efforts at Q Tech and so they're
sort of handsome who is an
experimentalist who works mostly on kind
of connecting these quantum processes as
Tim who mostly works in the local
quantum processes David Elko stalks
works quite a lot in simulations and
recently which I'll talk a bit more
about later and Slav are kind of works
on the physics of these kind of
processes and we also worked quite
closely with kind of an engineering team
at Pitino and they do some engineering
things sauce which is our project
manager who does this Foss and and he
for example they do kind of wavelength
conversion fast to connect alright so
this will be over
a kind of Dutch telecom network that use
the Dutch telecom kpn and who kind of
has fiber to connect these cities all
right so someone actually asked me
yesterday at a dinner and I realized
maybe I should explain a little bit kind
of order the elements of the quantum
Internet and so this is obviously a
cartoon but you can think that a kind of
quantum Internet is not so different
from a classical Internet and then the
objective is to kind of connect small
meaning a few qubit quantum processors
over potentially long distances so you
can think that evidently we have sort of
quantum processors somewhere like your
laptop and that are attached to fiber
and then the objective is to kind of
enable long-distance transmission and
this can be achieved on the ground by
something called a quantum repeater I
don't have time to talk about how that
works and or for example also by
satellites to kind of bring very very
large distances so you can sort of see
that there are several elements that one
went on to optimize here for example
like repeaters to go maximum distance
and also some capabilities of these n
nodes all right so I wanted to tell you
a little bit kind of for the state of
the art actually often say quantum
Internet and so we actually work on
ground-based efforts but like I said to
bridge ultra long distances there was
cool results recently from a group in
China that distributed entanglement over
the distance of 100 1000 and 200
kilometers through space which is pretty
cool all right so on the ground and a
kind of communication over Telecom
fibers has not been done over long
distances and I should say that sort of
some quantum protocols have been
implemented chiefly I guess mostly the
most famous one namely quantum
cryptography so there's a procedure for
exchanging encryption keys and so this
has been implemented at Short meaning
around a hundred kilometer distances now
you can buy such boxes and kind of
attach them and and also various other
kind of protocols have been implemented
at short distances so kind of the ground
challenge is I guess to bridge very
large distances
I you might also kind of Google around
on the internet and learn something
about a quantum network in China and for
example this one which is actually on
the ground and this is what's called a
trusted repeater network and so here the
only kind of application that can be
performed is called quantum key
distribution so the objective is to
exchange an encryption key between
Shanghai in Beijing and my life just
told you that currently we can only do a
hundred kilometers on the ground
this is evidently more than 100
kilometers so the way that kind of
trusted repeater networks work is that
say if Alice and Bob want to communicate
over long distances they use an
intermediate party saying a trusted
repeater and Alice generates a key with
a trusted repeater trusted repeater
generates the key with Bob and this
provided that they kind of trust the
trust that repeater allows them to do an
end-to-end encryption so I guess we
usually know how this in and so this is
obviously not kind of the desirable
situation and so the goal of course is
to go beyond that and really do
end-to-end qubit transmission all right
so there's obviously a question kind of
fun on how to how to go beyond kind of
this trusted repeater setting on the
ground and and we actually had a lot of
discussions about this how this can ever
work here this is actually from last
August and Marie did loves discussions
of what we want to do in in particular
we had a lot of discussion and this is
maybe it sounds kind of weird is what is
actually important to achieve okay so
what is a quantum internet and what do
we want to optimize for so you can think
about the capabilities of the nth notes
like how many qubits should they have
how important is storage and you can
think parsecs capabilities of the
repeaters like how to bridge sort of
long distances and of course they should
sort of kind of fit together
all right and you can also ask yourself
well how do we actually test that it
worked after we kind of set up something
outside so I don't have to talk and time
to talk about all of these things
obviously but I wanted to now actually
ask first talk a little bit about what
do we actually want to achieve here and
so run our hands on my my experiments
college I had a huge number of
discussions on this and we have actually
now defined sort of some as a series of
functionalities and you can think that
like each sort of stage of a quantum
internet and don't give you a
well-defined sort of set of extra
functionality at the expense of of
course Roger large and ever-increasing
experimental difficulty so you can think
that where we are now is kind of this
trusted repeater networks so these kind
of risks but they're kind of failures
with trivial and so the next kind of
thing that one might want to do is what
we called a prepare and measure Network
and this maybe also gives an indication
or really that this being somewhat
simpler than the quantum computing and
so basically we can think of this
network prepare measure of having the
capability of sending and measuring
single qubits
so this means that any two nodes in a
network and any node can kind of perform
and I'll prepare an arbitrary qubit
transmitted to the to the other node and
they can perform an arbitrary
measurement and post selected means that
kind of the receiving node either kind
of managers to perform the measurement
or declares that the state is lost so as
long as the kind of community of post
selection is not too large in fact this
already allows you to do quantum key
distribution yeah yeah so and maybe to
be clear so note that kind of here like
you want this functionality between any
end nodes in the network okay and of
course like how difficult this is to
realize
even classical transmission for short
distances can become clear and so so
like of course how how difficult is to
realize this depends also on the extent
of your network right and so if you're
only at 100 kilometres and I mean this
is possible the end-to-end if you even
have some kind of optical switch for
example so here I'm only talking about
kind of the application driven
functionalities not how they are
realized this is kind of an important
distinction but you can get a little bit
more complicated and actually now ask
that we can generate end-to-end
entanglement between any two nodes in a
network and now we have a slightly
larger demand in the sense that we want
this end-to-end entanglement not to be
post selected and that we wanted to be
deterministic or horizon so her all that
simply means that I have a signal that
says I've made entanglement that is
independent of what happens on the local
nodes all right you can also imagine
that kind of you have quantum memory
networks and this kind of becomes a
little bit more complicated and we've
defined in such a way of course you may
have more qubits but that you can
generate with the APIs we have all the
functionality from below and you can
prepare at least one qubit in finland
you can measure in qubits at the node
you can have an application of an
arbitrary unitary and you have some
storage time and here the storage time
of interest is defined by the maximum
time that it is necessary to send
classical information from one node to
the other so note that also kind of what
this means here depends on the diameter
of my network and and of course kind of
the number of rounds of communication I
want to achieve
so maybe importantly is that here we do
make absolutely no demands on this being
kind of fault tolerant in any any sense
of course you might imagine that
somewhere in the very far future viewers
have fault-tolerant quantum processors
in fluid fronting computers that might
also get attached to the network but so
we are aiming to go up to here namely a
kind of quantum memory Network and
having of course define sort of series
of functional gives us a guideline for
a protocol design and also for tests so
this is one of my students Victoria and
she's currently kind of working on say a
certain test suit to that you can sort
of run to say okay if I if I pass on
this test then I'm kind of em in this
particular stage right so let me now say
a little bit kind of what quantum
networks can do so this is not a kind of
an exhaustive list and but there's
several applications known of quantum
Internet that kind of go beyond quantum
key distribution so the most famous one
electron configuration can be realized
in this prepared measure stage there's a
few other tasks here for example certain
two-party crypto talks like
identification and position verification
and other protocols it's fitting here
entanglement distribution allows you to
realize something called device
independent protocols I guess a lot of
you are quantum so you notice everything
and if everyone else this means that you
don't need to trust the quantum devices
so even if I kind of buy it from
somewhere else I can nevertheless use it
to achieve security in my protocol
provided I cross trust the classical
device and as in quantum my networks you
can see that one can do a lot more now
and there's all kinds of protocols for
like I guess at least clock
synchronization over limited time and
that has been proposed here maybe most
interestingly I would like to mention
that they have been protocols proposed
kind of for quantum communication to
solve certain problems and distributed
systems and someone yesterday also asked
we can quote this exactly means so for
the physicists here give me give them me
give you a cartoon of quantum computer
sort of computer science physical
systems and so it's often important to
synchronize resources in a network or
the marshal access to resources and I
guess a cartoon version of such a
problem is imagine that kind of you have
money in the bank and it's of course
redundant we store them from backup
servers let's assume that you're rich we
have four million dollars on your bank
account you withdraw the money and the
system crashed while you withdraw so non
server one says you have a million
dollars the other one says that he has
zero dollars so this is not such a
desirable
in a situation the people in computer
science have thought a lot about this
because for the physicists here and
there are all kinds of advantages known
in the quantum domain for solving such
talk maybe the last thing I want to
mention kind of if you really had large
quantum computers attached people have
also kind of proposed for example Monod
right protocols who are safe in
communication and not in computation
time but then we really kind of need
much more qubits so I want to give you
some kind of state of the art for the
system that we are using I guess in
Delft is the same that we've used for
this kind of loop or free Delta some
years ago and I just gives you some kind
of numbers which are partially projected
this one is a projected one and so these
nodes have around six cubits this may
seem very few from the quantum computing
domain but it's actually a lot for
quantum network applications and this is
kind of the current storage time and
this is an entangling rate so how
quickly can we generate entanglement
between these network nodes yes of
course all kinds of other people who
have thought about these things there's
also some groups in years who use a
similar system for example at Harvard
and MIT and this there are people who
used to do this in ion traps like Kris
Munroe and also in Europe for example
Tracy Northrop or who we also work with
and there's a number of other kind of
approaches
okay so Krista I asked her like who's
going to give this talk are they going
to be like squads of people that I
described a classic concealer or where
who are they and contain it okay there's
going to be mostly people from the
quantum architectures group so I
actually decided to to talk about a very
quantum thing is for the quantum people
here even though somehow a lot of work
that we've done recently is rather
classic shape and not so much quantum
and I'm going to talk a little bit about
this afterwards section so I wanted to
show you a kind of one procedure now
which relates to estimating the capacity
of a quantum Shannon let me kind of ask
for this question is it is motivated by
the following so let's say that Alice
and Bob are connected by a direct
quantum community communication channel
and they use the quantum repeater you
want to have a test or some measure that
tells you that kind of this repeater
actually improves the situation over
having no repeater okay so would be nice
as a repeater would be better than
having no repeater and this of course
all census measures one could can think
of but one of them is in fact motivated
by I guess information theory and mainly
the capacity of a channel so there's a
number called the capacity associated
with all kinds of communication channels
and in particular one can consider the
capacity of the direct communication
channel the capacity is basically the
number of bits transmitted divided by
the number of channel users maximized
over all possible encoding and decoding
skills and this also can be defined in
the quantum case for the classical
people here so of course one could now
do an experiment that says you know I
want to demonstrate that the rate of
communication with the repeater is
larger than the capacity of the direct
connection
and this can be can be done for example
one way to do this kind of for sending
key and so this one of my students
Kenneth has also derived some bounce for
capacities for producing piece and
quantum the private capacity capacity
for producing key and it's basically you
computers or computer bound honest and
then you implement the quantum key
distribution scheme to observe that the
rate of producing key is larger than the
rate of and that you calculate from the
direct communication shop
now the question is now can you do
something similar and for sending qubits
so it is actually harder to send qubits
meaning the capacity quantum capacity is
in generally smaller than the private
capacity and so can we make a test where
we can also demonstrate that the
repeater improves your abilities to send
qubits and not just to produce key and
so for this and of course first you want
to know something about the capacity of
the direct communication channel there's
all kinds of things known about that
there's also I want to point out some
very nice work and that studies this in
the finite n machines are not using
infinitely many channel uses but a
finite number sense so this we can sort
of do or kind of look up in the
literature and then we want to of course
now do a test to demonstrate that the
rate at which we can send qubits is
larger than this capacity of the direct
connection okay so let me paint a
cartoon okay if I have a quantum memory
or quantum communication channel so
communication channel going from the
left to the right I might of course use
an encoder and the decoder like David
for example gave you such things for
fault tolerance schemes so you can think
that here we only want to compute the
identity you ever want to do any case
you only compute the identity and we
would like to know how well can this be
done okay so this is a given here and
who wants to know
how well could we send information given
any possible encoder in a coder I should
say that this can also be used not just
to test physical devices but this could
also be logical qubit gates to this kind
of a memory which is a very ingenious
so some attempts is of course we could
implement a quantum error correcting
code we just take our Cuba to be encoded
we send it across we decode it and we
demonstrate that we can have achieved
good transmission of some fidelity and
the conclude that we can send
information at a certain rate so this of
course means that we have to implement a
quantum error correcting code okay so
this would require that we have quantum
computers on the less than the rights
actually decently large that can import
a certain number of qubits you could
also say let me put it as a device or
maybe I can estimate the diamond norm or
other measures this of course would be
nice but first the fine and we maybe
have to make some assumption then then
at least the son is sent many times or
have memory say many many memory pieces
maybe I want to assume that they are the
same but this is actually almost never
of that form so any communication
channel or physical device usually has
some kind of memory and second of all
are there some bad news in the sense
that even if you would know em in fact
we don't immediately know what the
capacity actually is this bound floated
it don't in general knowledge so the
goal is that we want to achieve here if
we want to estimate this constant
capacity directly it should work for
ends of any device in particular devices
also that have correlated noise and we
only wanted to do extremely simple
operations so to be very specific okay
let me now salient bit what exactly we
want to estimate by this capacity and I
have now not assumed that here we have
kind of what's called iid noise so the
noise would be the same on each qubit
but basically it's some kind of giant
noise channel arbitrary correlated nor
in several areas so we have an encoder
and a decoder which doesn't actually
exist
but we wanted to say if we have this
encoder and decoder how good could we do
and we're now interested in the
following quantity which is known as the
simple short capacity of a quantum
Channel
I guess there's not some quantum people
here so not a level compared with me
so what does this quantity measured
so let's think first about the fidelity
of transmission so if I started with a
state file I could think about what
happens if i encode that state then kind
of noise process is applied ID code and
then I'm interested in the overlap for
the fidelity between the input state and
whatever comes comes out for my decoding
screen so we want to be kind of smart
about them okay like and so I'm allowed
to use kind of any possible decoder and
encoder but we also saw this little bit
kind of pessimistic in the sense that
I'm interested in the worst case of the
fidelity okay I'm looking at the worst
case of sending transition and of course
kind of say the divorce case fidelity
and maximize the world possible encoding
and decoding schemes I can think about
well how large is my input space that I
can actually kind of transmit and so the
single shot fidelity is nothing else
than the log of kind of this maximum
input dimension such the diversity
fidelity is not smaller than 1 minus
epsilon for some fixed Epsilon of course
for example if epsilon is 0 so I don't
have any demands
then of course my official capacity is
very high if my fidelity is excusing my
worst case fidelity is extremely close
to 1 okay then I can send less
information at the track all right so
the goal is now to estimate this thing
and maybe to be clear I now wanted to
estimate it using only single qubit
preparations and measurements along to
only kind of prepare and measure single
qubits at a time and objectives will be
that from whatever data with measures we
will apply some function and we'll get a
bound on the disk capacity so maybe you
need to say one thing the objective here
is only to estimate a lower bound and
not an upper bound and upper bound if
you allow arbitrarily correlated noise
because it can kind of conspire against
you to do something else in every single
instance to kind of trick you into
believing that the capacity is low when
actually it might be high
but actually for all applications it is
enough to show that the capacity is
large so that the channel is good look
at the channel is bad
so there's a very simple protocol
actually and that basically kind of uses
ideas from quantum key distribution and
that is based on the idea that if we can
transmit in two complementary bases
through a channel then we can also send
qubits very well so basically what we do
is we just kind of randomly prepare
eigenstates of Sigma X and Sigma set we
do this very many times and you measure
it in the same basis and we measure the
error rate of sending information in the
X basis and the error rate of sending
information in the databases so the kind
of procedure here is very simple and of
course some kind of theoretical analysis
which I'm not going to talk about and
from this one can conclude that either
the data is highly unethical or the
physical statement we have a precise
statement of course or indeed the
quantum capacity is large large meaning
like the number of of transmissions that
we've done here the preparation quality
occurs for perfect X and Z this would be
one if my bases are not perfect but
somewhat more close together can become
smaller this is the binary entropy of
the error rate of X and this the binary
entropy of the error rate or set I'm
putting under the hood here and like all
kinds of finite size effects but you can
look here for the formal theorem and
some actually test that we've also done
using the superconducting qubit
okay so this is life because we can now
actually just using single qubit
preparations and measurements also test
where that one of the quantum repeater
repeats qubits are not just so of course
this various analysis that has been done
and on the basis of this one can do an
analysis like which regimes don't have
to be in in order to kind of beat these
bounds and such things we have done with
my colleague Rolla then also with with
my collaborator Tracy and rapidly
running out of time and I'm only getting
to this but I will be very brief yet
okay so it's given that we actually have
this excellent opportunity to kind of
set up this demonstration network in the
Netherlands we have decided that this
will be a university program of the
content network in particular we want to
have the capability to actually execute
kind of any sort of funding program
networks and protocol on these kind of
quantum devices and you can now think
actually about how would I now go about
programming a quantum network and I
guess for the physicists here there's
sort of an additional this complication
in the sense that I don't program just
on my local computer
but I have at the bottom the hardware ok
these kind of changes qubits I have
somewhere at the bottom some application
like a protocol but just on paper versus
Ellison to Cuba to Bob and then Ellis
measures physical assistant but there's
of course some classical communication
required between Alice and Bob to make
that happen that sort of needs to match
together with what happens down here the
same actually goes also if we wanted to
kind of route qubits around but I'm not
going to talk about it here so in order
to kind of think about this we have
realized a network simulator actually it
is designed solely for the purpose to
explore the kind of program disk or
network application and it essentially
sort of replaces this hardware by say a
virtual quantum mode like a little
server client server program you can
actually install on different laptops
and they can talk to each other by
classical communication kind of
simulating this quantum communication so
I mean let me say a little bit on how
this kind of works actually I will not
say not how this works but I will maybe
say how it is different
then kind of an a kind of standard
simulator and so in fact this can use
actually any sort of simulator as a
back-end that kind of can talk to Python
we actually use q-tips but you can also
use maybe project you more or less it is
very easy to change that actually
certain and what it allows you to do is
where you can start up various kind of
virtual quantum mode and you can also
kind of have notice classical program
basically it will you can have classical
communication between these two and you
can access as you would I guess with
hardware and they create new qubits
measure qubit send instructions to
perform things and also send
instructions to send qubits to other
nodes in the network indeed select
Oxitec suffixes I will not say kind of
how the simulator works but I would want
to say that one thing that makes it
different kind of sets simulating things
locally okay so of course I can have a
locally simulated quantum register say
using YouTube whatever get in there I
can have qubits let me make some cubed
objects okay that can be somewhere in
this register and I want to represent
them using virtual qubits that kind of
are attached to these cubed objects now
of course one thing that kind of the
content network does is that it allows
two nodes to have two entangled qubits
but the world point of entanglement is
an I can not represented by local
classical information so for this reason
kind of I need to think about if these
kind of two network nodes have qubits
where are they actually simulated so
this essentially distributed simulation
so note that also this node may know
clearly have a simulated quantum
register with some qubits and maybe the
virtual qubit is actually simulated over
here so kind of the challenge in this
simulation or actually only challenging
the simulation of distinguishes for a
normal one is to basically perform the
50px simulations and keep track so say
for example make an entangling gate here
we now need to decide where these qubits
going to be simulated here here or or
there
it's not going to release this but I
have however given it to some of my
colleagues in main software engineering
and and then are playing around with
kind of program list which is actually
pretty cool so I enjoyed it right so let
me maybe say one more thing and which I
guess is quite a computer science
question but if you think about kind of
how to sort of make to quantum a quantum
particle and work in an actual network
and you will also realize that there's
an essential difficulty I guess if
you've ever thought about kind of
network protocols a protocol stack is
that a very serious man - but I'll give
you one simple example so if you
transmit information over classical
networks there's a very convenient thing
in the sense that you can have a header
that says like where does the packet
come from where does it go to and
conveniently the data is of course also
classic you okay so the whole thing
header and classical data can kind of
travel across the network together so
this is kind of not the case here okay
produced n qubits are here and kind of
classical data travels over there kind
of classical networks and of this
control information and so together with
actually one of Moloch students and one
of my films they're currently working on
various iterations of kind of a stacks
that prevents this question the first
one being is a classical quantum
combiner so after this you will only see
you have will have matched the header
information to the qubit information so
they are getting together and based on
this you can then run all kinds of other
protocols to keep track of entanglement
on top of them all right so I want to
mention a few other things I del so in
fact we can now distill entanglement
thanks to my excellent colleague and
David actually work together with some
people from tno
and we now have a different kind of
simulator actually that can be used to
test really the performance of protocols
of the repeater schemes which is a
discrete-time event simulation so what
does this move so in a network protocol
timing delays are extremely important
and I just maybe you remember a long
time ago I said to this coherent sounds
like one second not very long
but this means that the time that it
takes for messages to travel noise is
crucial and with this community I
actually wanted to explore certain
designs of repeaters and nodes and also
the placement of these nodes for example
in an evidence and such that you can
have end-to-end cubed transmission at
certain fidelity imma talk can talk to
you more about this so it's actually
quite fun and this relates to sort of
transforming states in a network if you
want to can tell you about it and also
of course there's interesting
applications for example and also my
students pension I'm officially out of
time now but there's kind of too many
questions again so within stages there's
now a question kind of order actually
the best tests to check that I'm at that
fit and it would be extremely
interesting of course to find protocols
in the more lower stages so I've given
you all these kind of tasks that can in
principle be solved by quantum network
and maybe there's an exciting new ones
but of course the desire the objective
is now to realize at protocol is to find
the protocol to solve a particular task
in its lowest stage of possible and
we've also estimate the default capacity
I quite sure this might not be the most
efficient way to go about this but there
might be others and yes you can try this
from physics so if you wanted to send
vlogging in 2020
I will also answer the question from the
panel discussion yesterday where do you
go if you want to learn about quantum
technologies I'm evidently totally
biased so we actually have a hammer have
a master project in it and then we also
often have open positions which you can
check here all right thank you very much
great Thank You Stephanie other
questions
great chubby
thanks for a nice talk sachet I have a
question about the program Network part
so actually I I want you have to watch
the I mean what's the I say the first go
the project it's like any like
purification that you want to achieve
with that kind of simulation or you know
anything mean maybe you're having your
mind but I haven't talked me into some
talk well so this so the object is that
we wants to achieve here
actually there's I guess two or two
objectives one of them really relates to
how do you program a quantum network
okay this may like it is not so true
running even if you think about a
totally trivial protocol which is like
this Alice and Bob generated EPR plan
they measure to generate a random coin I
don't know why but let's say they do and
already already this kind of if you
think about how do you go from this
description to connecting it with the
kind of qubits in the hardware is
complicated you have to kind of know for
example which of these qubits in my
hardware device is the right qubit and
how do these things kind of fit together
maybe you even want to be able to run
several applications at the same time
and it's it's quite complicated and in
order to explore that if you've
generated this simulator and in fact the
first I guess this like on the one hand
we're exploring this kind of protocol
stack like this classical Fontan
compiler and on the other hand kind of
we are actually using that to then sort
of investigate how to program really
applications using that stuff I think
this is something actually that's the
some extent you have to try and which is
why we makes the simulation okay thank
you great well lunch is ready let's
think Stephanie again for a wonderful
talk
let's resume at 1:15 and if anyone is
looking for some vitamin-b it's a
beautiful day outside there are tables
right outside the conference center with
chairs and you're welcome to take your
lunch outside rather than just stay in
this room so lunch is here on the left
and come back at 1:15 thank you